my name is Hina I live in Mumbai in the  suburb of and Erie and M 20 years old  these street children don't receive any  support so we help to teach them after  school we give them books and food and  help them in the subjects they find most  difficult that might be in the Marathi  language or in English initially but I  do they  sorry I really enjoy teaching and  playing with the children I often worry  about having a proper profession I still  haven't found a job I really like the  teaching I do here is voluntary but I  learn from it and it is a meaningful way  to spend my time  I love Taemin I love Chinese food and my  favorite fruits are bananas and mangos I  would love to go to London one day or to  Dubai the pictures I've seen if it are  so beautiful I would really like to  achieve something in my life my mother  let me stay at school until the 12th  grade and I would like to repay her for  everything she has done for me what I  would like most is a regular office job  goodbye